[Musique]
el anziz hamidou bonjour merci de nous
avoir rejoint ce matin sur rtl france
alors on le disait le 31 mars 2011
mayotte est donc devenue département
français en disant est ce que l'on peut
dire que ce changement de statut à
améliorer un peu la situation des
mahorais bonjour et bien écoutez on ne
peut pas tellement dire qu'il ya eu des
bouleversements conséquente du à ce
changement de stature on a continué à
vivre comme avant alors même que les
aspirations de la population de mayotte
c'est de vivre dans un département
français
c'est à dire un département régie par
l'article 73 de la constitution
en résumé les mahorais aspirent à à
encore plus de république et la
république
ce don aspire à l'e mail est mort et
c'est la république sociale et ces deux
là où l'état est complètement absente la
république sociale ne s'applique pas du
tout à mayotte
mais comment vous expliquer justement
ces inégalités sociales qui persistent
entre mayotte et et le reste des
départements français bah écoutez nous
nous sommes issus d'une longue tradition
de colonialisme donc c'est depuis 1977
qu'on a été entre parenthèses
décoloniser mais la volonté de l'état
sait s'ils n'étaient pas de faire de
mayotte un département français
c'était à peut-être de d'inciter les
mauvais à prendre le chemin des comores
a à dire le chemin de l'indépendance
donc les mahorais ont résisté ils ont
affirmé à plusieurs fois par voie de
référendum qu'ils étaient des citoyens
français et qui tenait à le rester parce
que c'est leur volonté et c'est leur
droit de rester dans la république alors
mayotte également tristement connue pour
son insécurité
et son immigration clandestine on se
souvient en 2018 un grand mouvement
social qui avait dénoncé cette réalité
aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'on en est est
ce que l'état mais suffisamment de
moyens pour répondre à ces problèmes
ben comme je vous le dis il ya un manque
de volonté politique de faire aboutir le
projet de départementalisation effective
de mayotte
donc on y raconterait le gouvernement
par plusieurs fois par plusieurs
blocages de grèves et de mouvements
sociaux pour le ramener à la raison et
de lui dire que l'application de la loi
c'est l'égalité républicaine et c'est
l'égalité républicaine
on ne peut pas y déroger parce qu'il n'y
a pas de négociation possible pour
l'égalité soit l'égalité républicaine
s'impliquent soit elle ne s'applique pas
et pour le cas de mayotte l'égalité
républicaine doit s'appliquer
parce que le statut politique de l'île
de mayotte c'est d'être régi par
l'article 73 de la constitution
c'est-à-dire l'assimilation légistatives
et de l'égalité sociale concernant la
question de l'immigration clandestine ça
reste un problème majeur aujourd'hui
pour les mahorais ce un problème majeur
pour l'état
parce que l'état est garant de la
sécurité publique est garant aussi de la
protection des frontières
donc aujourd'hui nous pensons donc que
l'état est en train de faillir à ses
obligations
c'est à dire pour une portion de mer de
insignifiant on n'arrive pas à repousser
les assauts des saisines d'idc immigrés
et on le laisse rentrer pour les faire
éloigner par la suite dans ce jeu à ce
jeu là c'est l'état qui est perdante
parce que ça freine considérablement le
développement de l'île et je ne sais pas
si c'est une volonté politique de
freiner le développement de l'île mais
encore
faudrait-il prouver que l'état est
responsable dans tout ça mais pour ma
part moi je pense qu' il manque de
volonté politique
si l'état décidé de protéger les
frontières et de faire développer
mayotte s'il y avait cette volonté
politique là en quelques mois mayotte
ressemblerait à un vrai départements
français comme l'est la réunion et les
antilles guyane au niveau du pacifique
de l'atlantique
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas en fait de
mea culpa la population est victime de
l'inaction de l'état ici à mayotte alors
la grande pauvreté à l'actrice de
l'immigration clandestine à la crise
sécuritaire s'ajoute aujourd'hui la
crise sanitaire comment est-ce que ça se
passe sur place
bah il n'y a pas de fatalité à se dire
la crise sanitaire les mahorais comme
toutes les autres populations au niveau
national et ses essais tant bien que mal
à respecter les gestes barrières et à
surmonter la difficulté du confinement
déconfinement et tout ça je pense que à
l'heure actuelle on s'en sort très bien
et le tout c'est que l'état puisse
accompagner la reprise et de l'économie
et qui est puis puisse aider les plus
nécessiteux à surmonter tous ces
difficultés-là d'oncomed globalement la
population tiens tiens tiens bien et au
niveau de deux du confort de vie et tout
ça ça s'est un peu dégradée mais je
pense que ça ira mieux quand l'état va
mettre la main à la poche et il va aider
toute cette population là merci el anziz
hamidou d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin sur rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes secrétaire général de l'udf au
mayotte